my guest tonight was the white house
communications director during george w
bush's presidency and a senior advisor
for the mccain palin campaign in 2008.
now she hosts deadline white house
weekdays
at 4pm eastern on msnbc
i've asked her to join us here today i'm
very grateful because i think
maybe she can enlighten us please
welcome nicole
wallace hi nicole thank you for doing
this such a pleasure
thanks for having me you realize you
said it's a pleasure as you shook your
head no
i'm new to zoom i was trying to figure
out where to look you know yeah
okay okay in my basement
my whole teenage my whole teenage uh
life was me saying to
two women would you like to maybe go get
a soda with me and i'm going
uh it sounds like a great idea yeah
let's think about that
so i know what you were doing
involuntary movements maybe
involuntary movements um here's the
problem
i think i speak for so many people
right now which is we've been through
hell the last two days and i am finding
that the more
i watch television almost the less i
know
we've hit an inflection point if i see
john
king with that stupid map one more time
tell me about a district that hasn't
come in yet
in some part of the country i've never
heard of where there's six
votes maybe i'm gonna start hitting
people
just randomly hitting people so tell me
first of all we are taping this it is uh
11 30 a.m and it is
thursday and so things may have changed
dramatically
by the time people watch this tonight
uh do you think it's possible that we
could
have um i'm not going to call them the
winner but
the major networks call a
a uh a winner in this presidential
contest
today could that happen it could happen
today i'll tell you
the network so it's a very weird
cycle and and i'll just say compared to
four years ago this week
i'd take this scenario as exhausting and
as
tedious as it is over what happened four
years ago because
i'll tell you the view from both the
biden orbit
and the trump orbit is that joe biden is
most likely the next president of the
united states
so a trump source told me yesterday that
these lawsuits because
other than the map that's the other
thing we're talking about on tv
that these lawsuits are mostly designed
and ordered up by the client who's
donald trump and if you remember when
his fixer michael cohen testified you
know
who who had the job of bringing a lot of
lawsuits for donald trump when he was a
private citizen
they're usually without cause without
merit they're
they're punitive they're to settle
scores or to settle bridges
in donald trump's mind i think they are
to
save him or spare him from the
humiliation of rejection
which you know folks that have followed
his personal life
know that that is the thing he fears
more than anything i don't think he's
afraid of not being in charge of the
country i think he's afraid of being
rejected
he is petrified petrified of losing
nobody
likes to lose um i can speak
personally you do get used to it
accustomed to it in time it becomes a
part of life
uh but uh he fears it
greatly and i think what he really wants
to do in my opinion
is throw up a lot of dust and i think
what
what the trump strategy now is most
likely
i do not get a second term but what i
want
all of my followers to think is that we
were robbed
and it's almost it's a bloody shirt that
he and his people and his family can
wave
uh for the next 20 years
with whatever they're doing and that's
what it feels like this is all set up
for
that's what it is but that's how he
governed as president when he won
when he won it was all about getting
robbed when he won
four years ago instead of being honored
and humbled
and reading for the first time and
listening for the first time
he spent four years talking about being
robbed and
investigated and attacked he never slid
into the role
this will be a much more comfortable
adjustment to actually be rejected
and to actually make up a cover story
for it
than it was for him to have won four
years ago i mean he never
made that leap so i think that the
the flip side of this which people in in
my line of work are doing
a real i think injustice and not
spending as much
attention talking about is that yes
donald trump
has most likely been rejected joe biden
has most likely
won after losing the first three
democratic primary contests
spectacularly after being left for dead
politically
by the democratic elite by the media he
went on to have this incredible
victory in the south carolina primary he
then had
really you talk about landslides and
waves he had a landslide wave victory
in super tuesday and then to beat a
republican
in this age of fox news we talk about
fox because they're sort of the tallest
building in that universe but there's a
whole um
fake news ecosystem that
we will look back in a few years and
find it remarkable that
anybody could get through and
win in this kind of political climate
you know you spent many years formative
part of your career
working for and with republicans
and i'm curious because i'm trying to
look
forward now the specifics of what
happens
tonight or tomorrow in the next few days
we can't say right now we think we know
what's going to happen but let's look
farther forward what is the republican
party
do now because there are a lot of people
like myself
i'll be honest with you i say this i
must have said this a million times
i don't get as angry at donald trump
because i look at him
as uh i think a lot of people would
agree a malignant narcissist
was the term which is used a lot he's
someone who has a condition
um probably needs to be treated the the
people i
reserve my true anger for are the
enablers within the republican
party who have just gone along and it
they've all been in lockstep
and i'm sort of a history buff i'm hard
pressed to think of another president
that had the total zombie-like control
of his party like donald trump
not no one breaks ranks they're all
terrified of him
so what happens how does the republican
party
move forward from this point or do they
not is it going to be
still trump's party look this is my
private pain
usually i mean this party that
justifiably gave the bush family um
and you know i've talked about this
before uh who i worked for such a hard
time
um never hesitated to criticize an
effective and that was healthy i you
know i'm not complaining about that i'm
just saying i know the republican party
is capable of saying screw you to a
republican president because i saw it
um to see them be so subservient
uh in the face of a man who doesn't
believe in anything they believe in and
you can argue
that the base of the party's more where
trump is on foreign policy
and trade that might be true but the
republican
elected officials are not they believe
the stuff that
former republicans and former republican
nominees used to believe in
so to have sort of capitulated on their
own
ideology and then to capitulate it on
their own
souls is to me the most dangerous
dynamic
in the era of trump because what's
happening right now
is that people around trump are saying
it's over
it's not clear to me that anyone has
walked in and told him that he may have
figured it out because he watches
he's an incessant consumer of cable news
and i think even on
fox news while some of the folks in the
evenings they're
cheering these really sort of illogical
and and non-formal
lawsuits i mean in one state they want
the boat to keep going and another they
want it to stop and another
they want ballots stuck in i mean you
know they don't want one thing across
country so
the fact that so many people allow him
to um really desecrate the presidency
is to me the irreparable piece of his
tenure
which looks like it'll only be four
years but i don't think there is
something on the other side
it's it's you know how do you build that
back if you if you're supposed to i mean
not something on the other side for the
republicans because that's my curiosity
is
these republicans right if you're and i
i have
friends people i went to college with
who we we didn't agree on
they're smart uh you know they're very
intelligent
well-read uh people who have who really
love their country
who uh we didn't always see eye to eye
because they would vote republican
uh i would vote democrat but
we would have long conversations and we
shared a lot of values
and now i think we've gotten to the
point where um
those people those friends of mine have
wanted no part of trump or trumpism
so you wonder is how does the republican
party
how does it encapsulate or how can it be
big enough a big
tent that holds reasonable people
and people that believe in their hearts
that joe biden is a pedophile and drinks
the blood of children in satanic rituals
how do you do that i don't know that
there's a party there
look i mean that's a q and on um
conspiracy yeah
i didn't know what q anon was until very
recently i mispronounced them i saw them
in my teleprompter and called them
like queen on one on
um look i don't think
it's oil and water right q anon
is a toxin and i don't think you can say
like oh i'll just
swim with them so it is it is
they are mutually exclusive and what the
party has become doesn't have room for
reasonable people
i think the smart line of questioning
that you're pursuing
is at this point unknowable
because i think that winning campaigns
always overread their mandate
and senate republicans will think they
won this
because they didn't lose as many seats
as they thought and even if donald trump
is rejected i think they will misread
what might have been a lot of anxiety
about shutdowns
and about maybe over i think republicans
have been conditioned to believe
that shutdowns and lockdowns and public
health
safety measures are against the
interests of our economic security
and i think that is not what joe biden
has been saying but i think that's where
that sort of toxic mix of disinformation
and misinformation and painting all
democrats
as socialists has will make it difficult
for him to lead the whole country
because i think half the country truly
thinks he wants to to shut people down
and leave them in their homes
that is not even the public health
approach but
i i think that until you have a party
that understands that that dynamic
worried about the economy worried about
the shutdowns had more to do
with republicans looking healthier on
tuesday night and some of these senate
races than even a lot of republicans
thought they might
than any sort of mandate for trump or
trumpism or what they're doing
um i think they will continue down this
path and i think flirting with q and on
and playing ftse with white supremacists
is it is it is a dead-end road it's a
cul-de-sac there is no
what's the gop on the other side it has
to you know sort of
collapse and it might in the next cycle
of the cycle after that
and then you know maybe maybe something
thoughtful
comes up uh on the other side maybe it
doesn't you know
maybe we have this sort of corrupt half
of
of the political you know machinery and
and maybe that's what democrats have to
figure out how to contend with
i don't see clearly what the future is
for the two-party system
yeah i i don't think any of us really do
or if it is two parties i don't know if
it's these two parties um
one question is what does
biden do let's assume for a second
that biden is declared the victor and
passes all of these
lawsuits and is inaugurated how does he
lead this country
he doesn't have the senate um he has
he barely won by one of the thinnest
margins there'd been other very thin
margins obviously but
he won by a thin margin and how do you
govern how do you get a country
to come with you people talk about and
biden said it i want to unite this
country
i don't know if this country is unitable
and i'm
i like to think of myself as a an
optimistic person but i think sometimes
think short of an alien invasion
where all of us have to come together
and fight the aliens that are coming to
get us
from uh you know planet z-bar um
we i don't know what's going to bring us
together well look i would argue that
that half 40
of the country wouldn't believe they
were aliens they would think they were
you know
nancy pelosi's pet dragons i mean i
don't even think
i mean look i i thought about this this
i think about this all the time because
as you know i worked for a president two
and nine 911
um had the privilege of having a very
united country
for a while i mean some of his decisions
became among the most
polarizing in modern presidential
history but right for a spell
he had a very united country and
american people um
did more than their part they they
overcame fear they went back on
airplanes
um within weeks or months people were
flying on airplanes again
um and i think that if that happened now
i i think tf you look at the resistance
to weary masks can you imagine if 911
happened now
and the leader now had to convince
people that had to throw away their
liquids take off their shoes and be
frisked sometimes friskily
i think half the country would say you
know screw you yeah that violates my
that violates my rights
i have a right to get on an airplane
with a bottle of weird liquid
um and i don't want anyone touching me
yeah
so it could be ungovernable it could but
here's my thought about how binding
moves forward
i mean people just have to to put their
um their mouths and their tweets
and their behavior um you know where
their complaints have been
and for all the people that complained
mightily about what trump was and who he
was
um it would appear that the country
sided with them
and they're about to get rid of someone
that was leading our country down an
autocratic
despotic path it would appear and again
it's not done it would appear
that a plurality of people i mean in the
popular vote i think joe biden's lead is
more than four million and and i think
he'll end up with a sizable electoral
margin that the people pick the good guy
not the autocrat
and so i i think and this is always
easier to say from the other side of the
aisle but i think democrats will have to
resist the
temptation to go to war with themselves
it is a huge
deal to win in this climate where 40
percent of the country doesn't just
disagree with joe biden but as you said
thinks he's
a a socialist you know whatever qnon
called and pedophile
i think i think people and for all the
republicans that came out the lincoln
project
those people have to be part of his
governing coalition and if he tries to
reform the supreme court
all the people that tried to get rid of
trump have to
work for joe biden and kamal harris's
success
right i'm curious because and this is
i'd like to pick your brain
the campaign strategist part of your
brain
if you're on trump's team you must be
thinking right now about all the missed
opportunities because as you said
we both know historically the incumbent
is
has a huge advantage and also in this
area
in a crisis and yes and then uh so
number one
there's uh kovid which
pretty much i mean trump himself said it
he said i'm a wartime president
he could have been a wartime president
if he had said
i take this really seriously and here's
what we need to do
he would have had the approval of so
many people
on the left suddenly and
then you look at picking an unnecessary
fight
with the ghost of john mccain in
arizona and the list goes on and on
and on of the things that he did that
i'm sure his strategist must have been
pulling their hair out because when you
look at the results now i know a lot of
um democrats are maybe disappointed that
this is this
close and they think how could it be
this close well
uh it on the republican side
they must be thinking this was very
winnable he could have had this
that is that is exactly the conversation
they're having not just on
the broader republican side but inside
trump's own circle that
and and he didn't need to do everything
different with covid he needed to do
it like 10 better he needed to figure
out
how it and and someone said this to me
on the saturday before the election
that if he loses it will be because he
could never be convinced that
actually doing the right thing for the
country would have been
good politics for him he just couldn't
be convinced of that
people try um he he also has
you know i mean i don't know jared
kushner so i don't say this with any
personal venom but he is in
so far over his head he he is running
the united states government all of it
and he ran the presidential campaign
and again this is misreading mandates
because trump won four years ago jared
thought he was really good at both those
things
he sucks about those things you know the
country was just primed for sort of this
radical disruption
of our you know sort of status quo in
our politics and
and trump wrote in and excited and
titillated people
but the notion that they were going to
be able to do things better than tony
fauci
and that they were going to and it
transcended into everything they knew
more about the pandemic than tony fauci
they knew more about
campaigning for president than you know
chris christie or the people around them
that have done it before
if he loses it won't be because people
didn't want him to succeed
they did desperately and if you said if
he had done a
decent job on covet it's not clear that
there is
a home run to be hit but he couldn't
even pretend
to care yeah about the way people are
living
in this time of the pandemic so
another prediction i'd love to hear
let's say it plays out the way we think
it's going to play out
let's say that that that biden has
declared the winner
my guess is trump doesn't concede
there's a bunch of lawsuits but my guess
is
they don't really go anywhere because
their their frivolous lawsuits and i
think the votes have been careful
what does he do between now if you had
to guess what does trump do between now
and inauguration day and by the way i
don't see him sitting up there
on the dais at the inauguration i think
he'll be
i think he'll pull a herbert hoover and
just take off
or to be fair john adams look
his folks uh his supporters and advisers
warned before the election that it and
it should be said that the biden
campaign the trump campaign
saw the race the same way coming into
this final weekend they saw trump as
as um tightening in the final week
but not with a clear path to 270. the
biden folks
really thought texas and i kept saying
this on election night i thought joy and
rachel says we're going to explode but
the fighting campaign didn't have
florida or texas on their path to 270. i
mean they were really
um singularly focused on those um on the
up upper midwest and pennsylvania
and and they always looked um within
reach in
in arizona but what the trump folks said
to me
was that it depends on how trump loses
and if he wins in a contested and close
race
he will probably uh forego
all of the traditions of a transition he
would be very unlikely to
invite joe biden to the oval office and
talk to him and frankly at this point
joe biden probably knows more about the
presidency than trump does
uh he would be very unlikely to
sit there for joe biden if he went to
meet with donald trump uh joe biden
might have to show him where the oval
office
the longest no no no is it's this way
it's over this one oh i didn't oh okay
you never that's a bathroom donald you
would have loved it i mean you know
but yeah luke i think you're absolutely
right
and and if you can think of other
traditions not so much public-facing
ones but traditionally
you let a president-elect's transition
team into the cabinet agencies to start
understanding
right these federal programs that no one
really talks about or sees much about
but
um you know i don't think any of that
will happen i think i think
biden's greatest sort of political
um hurdle was that he didn't really
thrill that the newly energized kind of
progressive base kind of
the aoc wing of the party but his
greatest gov
those things make him the strongest
person to come in and govern
after trump because having been there
for so long
and having um you know he's got
decades in the senate where he he was
synced up
policy wise with john mccain and ted
kennedy so he he knows kind of all sides
of these debates and the things that may
have weakened him in a democratic
primary
would probably strengthen him in a
transition to power after
just such a bizarre a bizarre presidency
that of donald trump
yeah well i guess we'll find out um
maybe by the time this airs they will
have called pennsylvania do you think
that's possible
it'll be tonight the latest i heard was
that
um and this again is
sort of the good news and the bad news
because these are so decentralized and
you've got these local
local government folks doing it you
really can't you know
rush the raspberry it'll be right when
it's ready they'll be done counting when
they're done counting and and so as you
i've never heard anyone say rush the
raspberry you know
when you when you want to eat the
raspberries off the bush i get it now
i get i've been around the block a long
time and i've never heard anyone but i
love it
i'm going to start it might be from a
cartoon
yeah hey we're not going to rush the
raspberry c
there'll be no rushing the raspberry on
my watch you can't rush the count
and so it's very unsatisfying so i think
that's why you see all this and i have
to say when i worked on campaigns i
could barely read a poll
so i i can barely read exit full data
they would come the pollster would walk
in
a wonderful guy named matt dowd he's
over on abc now and he'd say i've got
all the data and i'd say i can't
i can't even see numbers like just tell
me what we have to do do we have to be
nicer do we have to be calmer do we have
to be smarter
so i i can i i'm it all gets a little
blurry to me but my understanding is
that all the outstanding vote
in pennsylvania is acknowledged by both
campaigns
to be favorable to joe biden most likely
and that is why in pennsylvania the
strategy is to stop the counting
whereas in arizona where some of the
outstanding vote is expected to
add to both candidates columns the legal
efforts
are to i think keep the vote counting
isn't that fascinating yeah and you know
one of the things and and then we'll
i'll have to wrap it up but one of the
things that boggles my mind
is that so many um people are wondering
why are some of these
vote counts taking so long yeah and it's
because especially if you look
in pennsylvania it's republican uh
legislators that wanted it that way they
wanted the count to take
a long time trump wanted it to take a
long time
because they knew that the uh write-in
votes the mail-in votes the drop-off
votes would heavily favor the democrats
and they wanted those votes to come in
late so that they could seem
illegitimate so it's it's theater
it's just it's the whole thing is
theater it the whole thing is
playing out exactly as they wanted it to
right there's no reason
in this modern era even with kovid that
um that we couldn't have had these
results a lot earlier
but that is really important this was
their design
to corrupt our impression of the outcome
yeah
that strategy yeah that we would think
that donald trump was ahead and
and what was really dark and what is
really twisted is that
instead of trying to compete and say oh
it's a pandemic a lot of republican
especially republican seniors they may
want to vote for me by mail too
let me work on that program so that my
mailing vote is just as robust as his
it was just such a cynical play to say
i'm not going to give my voters the
option they're going to stand there damn
it in the middle of a pandemic that
happens to be surging right now
and so they they designed this and there
is just incredible irony
that that this will end up the fact that
we know that a lot of this outstanding
vote is for biden is because
donald trump didn't ever want it to be
counted and included
right and now they're saying well it's
very suspicious that it's coming in late
no it's not it came in on election day
or before it's only being counted late
because
you wanted it to be counted late so you
could do what you're doing now
it's very frustrating but i just
choose to drink a lot um i'm heavily
i'm heavily medicated uh i'm not even
sure
where i am right now the country is
telling me i just say though
we look at where we were four years ago
and
um and and we look at what we are
probably on the cusp of right now
this is a much better place to be
everything and i too
am eating um i mean my son's halloween
candy has been
inhaled and consumed and metabolized by
me
it is all gone i mean i i'm i'm i feel
because we're suspended we're paralyzed
you know um but i think it's gonna be
okay
no at halloween i just uh filled uh i
didn't even get candy i just put a giant
bowl of uh 10 milligram
klonopin pill out
and i gave them to everybody and
everybody on my street is feeling
my people kept coming back people kept
coming back masks no masks
falling asleep on my lawn it was a good
time nicole
um a delight talking to you and uh
um thank you so much i know you're
really busy and you've been
i think you've been like going 12-hour
days
24-hour days i since this
what am i gonna do right i mean i'm home
the studio's in the basement
right well okay all right fair point but
still
i'm saying uh you're you're you're
working around the clock and so for you
to take time for us was really nice
so it's really nice to see you and look
let's see how it goes
we will pick it up on the other side
we'll pick that would be nice let's talk
again
and um i'm sure america will immediately
snap back to normal
i
deadline white house uh airs weekdays
from
4 to 6 p.m eastern on msnbc
and uh just happy holidays and i look
forward to talking to you soon again
yeah let's keep it going thank you thank
you